bonjour c'est monsieur grenier quelques
jours vous ai fait une vidéo dans lequel
vous parlez du one + 6 juste après son
lancement est un autre officiel et dans
cette vidéo je dise effectivement que le
one + 6 étaient à mi chemin entre un
produit milieu de gamme et un produit
haut de gamme
ça m'a été reproché dans ta vidéo tu
compares loin de plus s'ils sont
induites de samsung tu dis que c'est un
moyen de gamme tu perd toute crédibilité
[Musique]
non plus sur les smartphones haut de
gamme et les smartphones android
là avec ce produit on est vraiment sur
un produit à cheval entre le haut de
gamme et le milieu de gamme
c'est ça qui pose problème on est
souvent produit à cheval entre le haut
de gamme et le milieu de gamme
est-ce que ce one + 6 est un produit
haut de gamme ou est ce que c'est un
produit milieu de gamme où est-ce qu'au
final c'est un peu des deux et c'est
justement cette distinction qui a posé
problème
[Musique]
soit
ce que
en cours
elle peut commencer par l'aspect
technique c'est les meilleurs qui existe
à ce jour le design est tout simplement
digne d'une ultra haut de gamme
l'écran amoled full hd plus l'expérience
utilisateur toujours magique
les mises à jour toujours présenter
régulièrement niveau vidéo vient du
super sur le mode du kabca 60 fps il
installe au double capteur photo de très
bonne qualité d'après les premiers tests
alors que à 8 tout ça c'est clairement
du moyen de gamme avec par la fiche
technique
bon je peux pas dire le contraire je
peux pas dire oui je peux pas dire non
alors moi ce que je propose c'est de se
poser la question qu'est ce qui définit
un smartphone haut de gamme par rapport
à un smartphone milieu de gamme
les deux choses qui rentrent en question
le premier c'est le prix et la deuxième
c'est les spécifications techniques
on va regarder ce ensemble d'un point de
vue comme de l'autre on va regarder au
final est-ce que ce one + 6 est un
smartphone haut de gamme
oui ou non
ce qui définit en partie un smartphone
c'est son prix si vous avez un prix très
élevé vous pouvez vous dire que c'est du
haut de gamme
a contrario pourrait dire que ceux du
bas de gamme par exemple pour un iphone
10 bon là ce que je veux dire ici c'est
pas que si un smartphone est cher ces
deux gammes et s'il est pas cher c'est
du bas de gamme ce que je veux juste
dire c'est que le prix est un bon
indicateur pour se rendre compte si le
produit est dans la classe des produits
haut de gamme ou s'il a la classe des
produits bas de gamme très clairement
pour faire un produit complètement
pourri qui coûterait très cher ça
voudrait pas dire pour autant que c'est
un produit haut de gamme
a contrario on pouvait faire un produit
qui est pas cher avec des spécifications
de fou et ça veut pas dire pour autant
que c'est un produit bas de gamme c'est
juste un indicateur et cette idée que je
développais revoilà c'est juste pour
éviter qu'ils étaient de confusion bon
on y retourne
si j'en veux un il va falloir que je
débourse la somme de 1159 non maintenant
si je veux un ace neuf de chez samsung
il va falloir que je dépense 859 euros
et si je veux un s9 plus falloir que je
paye 959 donc en toper 20 pro de huawei
il va falloir que je paye la petite
somme de 899 euros
là vous êtes très clairement sur des
produits haut de gamme a contrario pour
le moyen de gamme certains coûté un peu
moins cher si par exemple je veux 1 à 8
il va falloir que je débourse la petite
somme de 499 euros petit bien évidemment
pas si petit que ça et si je veux un
iphone est ce ça va me coûter 419 euros
alors où est ce que ceci tullow oil +6
dans tout ça ça c'est la question qui
est vraiment intéressante en réalité le
one + 6 il va coûter 5 119 euros pour la
petite config eelv a coûté 569 euros
pour la config intermédiaires et si vous
voulez la plus grande config il vous
coûtera 6 119 euros
donc là très clairement que de ce point
de vue là on voit que l'ovale plus et se
situe entre le haut de gamme et milieu
de gamme
on est vraiment entre les deux on peut
dire que c'est un milieu de gamme un peu
cher valoran haut de gamme pas cher donc
si le prix ne permet pas de définir six
points de plus si c'est un smartphone
haut de gamme ou de milieu de gamme
qu'est ce qu'il peut me permettre de le
voir effectivement alors on sait que le
prix ce n'est pas une science exacte de
toute façon c'est très clair qu'en
regardant le prix c'est pas ça qui va me
dire si le smartphone est un smartphone
haut de gamme ou pas mais néanmoins le
prix est ferme à se repérer par rapport
à une offre
au bal on voit qu'on est vraiment sur un
prix intermédiaire on va regarder
maintenant du côté des spécifications
techniques parce qu'à mon avis là on va
réussir un petit peu et qui resserrent
la chose ça c'est le papier que je vous
ai fait alors là vous avez fait une
fiche technique one + 6 p 20 pro s9 plus
l'idée effectivement c'est pas de
rentrer dans les détails parce que ça va
rapidement être complètement imbuvable
mais d'avoir une vue d'ensemble pour se
rendre compte si sur le papier ce one +
6 par rapport au peu d'impro et ouest
+96 les plus intéressants oui ou non
alors du point de vue de la fiche
technique le one + 6 un processeur
snapdragon 845 cadencé à 2,8 ghz pour
l'instant de sa dragonne 845 c'est le
processeur le plus performant de paul
comme donc en termes d'efficacité en
termes de capacité de puissance de
calcul on n'a rien à lui reprocher là
dessus il ya tout d'un grand boire il
est carrément un grand vous avez une
version cl gadrat mille versions 8 gigas
de ram vous avez 3 versions de stockage
68 128 256 go de stockage du point de
vue de ce côté-là ça fonctionne très
très bien aussi sur comparaître le pépin
pro vous êtes inquiet rinne 970 et avec
la sfef plus vous avez un exynos 9810
dans un cas comme dans l'autre
comme dans l'autre on a les puces les
plus puissantes du moment maintenant
tout ne va pas faire un comparatif de
ces trois puces ça n'aura également pas
de sens ici mais ce qu'on voit ce qui
est très révélateur c'est que là dessus
le one + 6 est vraiment en concurrence
avec les plus gros smartphone on va
regarder maintenant du point de vue de
l'écran sur le wan +6 vous avez un écran
amoled 6,28 pouces 19 neuvième
résolution de 2280 par 1080 pixels un
gorilla glass 5
si vous allez sans pépin pro vous avez
un écran oled 6,1 pouces 2240 par 1080
en écran légèrement plus petit et si on
va sur le s9 plus j'ai pris délibérément
la plus grande confier par rapport aux
us 9
on est sur un écran super amoled de 6,2
pouces 2960 par 1440 pixels là une fois
de plus on va que le one + 6 et à la
hauteur et au niveau des deux gros
smartphone choisi est maintenant au
niveau de la photo de la vidéo vous avez
un double capteur photo à l'arrière sur
le wan plus vous avez un sony et pix 519
16 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.7 et vous avez le deuxième c'est un
sony mx 376 cas 20 méga pixels avec une
ouverture de f
1.7 pouvait filmer en capita a 30 et 60
images par seconde
pouvoir du slow motion en 1080p en 240
images par seconde et en 720p en 480
images par seconde à l'avant vous avez
une caméra
une sonnerie mx3 71 16 mégapixels avec
une ouverture de f 2.0
on verra dès maintenant du côté du pépin
pro pour voir style et au niveau santé
impose d'un triple objectif un triplé
cac40 mégapixels avec l'ouverture de f
1.8 20 méga pixels avec une voiture de
f1 points 6 et 8 mégapixels qu'une
ouverture de f 2.4 à l'avant vous avez
un 24 mégapixels ouverture de f 2.0 sur
le s9 plus maintenant vous avez un
double capteur à l'arrière deux fois 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture variable
sur le premier de f1 points 5 à f 2.4 et
sans l'autre atteint de tels objectifs
avec une ouverture de f 2.4 et à l'avant
vous avez une caméra de 8 mégapixels
on peut bien évidemment filmé en cas de
cas vous avez aussi du super slow motion
960 images par seconde à 720p du côté de
la photo et de la vidéo on voit que le
one + 6 et franchement haut niveau alors
très clairement pour moi le p 20 pro et
le samsung galaxy s 9 plus se regarder
nos supérieurs par contre le one + 6
tire vraiment son épingle du jeu avec
des capteurs qui en tout cas on l'a
d'être d'excellents de bonne qualité à
voir maintenant lors d'un prochain test
mais en tout cas sur le papier
parfois les que c'est plutôt cool du
côté de la batterie et maintenant vous
avez une batterie de trois mille trois
cent millions paire eur avec une
recharge rapide en une demi heure de
charge vous avez chargé quasiment deux
persos de 3 4 65% à peu près ça l'a
globalement vite sur le p 20 euros vous
avez une batterie de capi 2 milliampères
heures tandis que sur le s9 plus vous
avez des batteries de 3500 milliards eur
du point de vue de l' os vous avez un
androïde oreo avec une surcouche oxygène
os sur le pépin pro vous avez un no 1 8
point sur un oréodont 8 points et se
relaient ce même plus vous avez aussi
honoré aux slovènes plus de vingt
bluetooth 5.0 du nfc un port jack de
l'usb type c'est sur le terrain prouser
du bluetooth 4.2 nfc usb type c'est sur
le s9 plus du bluetooth 5.0 prise jack
usb type c du point de vue
spécifications techniques ce qu'on voit
très clairement c'est que le one plus à
tout d'un grand
là on parle que suis-je technique on
sait qu'il est très compliqué de juger
un produit que par rapport à la fiche
technique alors c'est très clair que de
toute façon si le processeur si la carte
graphique
si la mémoire avis si le stockage sûr
c'était complètement à la rue il aurait
été très clair que ce smartphone
n'aurait pas pu dire qu'ils flirtaient
ou que c'est un produit bien voilà très
clairement là dessus les gens pètent
rassurer donc je vais devoir revoir ma
copie
initialement pour moi le wall +6 c'était
un smartphone milieu de gamme qui
flirtait avec le haut de gamme l'arbre à
jouer un peu différemment je vais
pouvoir tendance a dit
que le one piece 6 c'est un smartphone
haut de gamme qui flirte avec les prix
du mil et de diane voilà pour cette
vidéo dites nous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous pensez que sur une piste
un smartphone plutôt haut de gamme
plutôt milieu de gamme
est ce que vous l'avez essayé est ce que
vous avez envie de l'essayer pour ma
part j'ai pas encore pu le prendre dans
les mains rassurez vous ça ne saurait
tarder je vais faire mon maximum pour le
récupérer pour le tester dites-moi
attendant vous ce que vous en pensez est
ce que vous pouvez vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous avez envie de l'essayer
est ce que vous aimez ou en plus
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
smartphones de oued plus vous marquez
tout ça en commentaire comme d'habitude
je les ai laissé des jolies pousse des
commentaires vous marquez tout questions
suggestions tout ce que vous voulez
directement en bas restez connectés
abonnez vous parce que vous allez voir
il ya plein plein plein de nouveautés
plein de choses qui arrivent
donc on va se connecter en attendant je
vous dis merci à très bientôt et je vous
embrasse